تحدثنا عن حدودي خطر قد يلامسها السودان
ومنها الفساد وهنا الطريق معقده هل هو جاد
في محاربته والى اي مدى يمكنه الاستمرار
والى اي حد او بالاحرف ما هي الهوامش
المسموح بها
يواجهوا السوداني بلدا من اكثر البلدان
فسدا في العالم احتل العام الماضي المرتبه
المئه والسبعه والخمسين عالميا بين 180
دوله بحسب منظمه الشفافيه الدوليه
الفساد المستشرم في كل مفاصل الدوله ممثله
الامين العام للامم المتحده في العراق
جنين بلس حار تقول ان الفساد الجزء من
الحياه اليوميه خسر العراق بسببه
450 مليار دولار من وزناته العامه بين
عامي 2003 و2/2015 اي اكثر من نصف موازنته
العامه التي بلغت ثماني 150 مليار دولار
خلال تلك الفتره وهذا الكلام لرئيس
الوزراء الاسبق عادل عبد المهدي
طيب ماذا لو قلنا ان نحو خمسين الف موظف
وجندي في وزاره الدفاع ليس لهم وجود
ويتقاضون الرواتب هذا فعلا ما كان يجري
بحسب رئيس الحكومه الاسبق ايضا حيدر
العبادي في سبتمبر 2014
150 مليار دولار موهبه من عوائد النفط منذ
عام 2003 تقديرات اخرى تقول ان المبالغ قد
تصل الى 600 مليار دولار وفي فتره زمنيه
اقل هي ما بين 2006 و28
هنا مثلا في حقل الزبير النفطي دارت
عمليات تهريب تورط في تورط فيها ضباط
بيرتها بين عاليه وموظفون كبار والعمليه
كانت تتم عبره احداثه ثقوب بين خطوط
طير النفط الكميه المهربه فذرت بكم بحدود
خمسه الى سبعه صهريج وبسعه 50,000 لتر
يوميا وبما يصل الى 75 مليون لتر الشهريه